chelsea's with us in fayetteville
arkansas hi chelsea how are you
great how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i am thinking about starting a
non-profit and i'm wondering
at what point if any is it okay to
budget a salary
for myself in the time that i would sit
and doing it
well of course i mean at some point if
you're going to run that full time you
would have to figure that out but let's
back up a step so
so at what stage are you in in in
thinking about starting this you've
already got a business plan an idea
specific audience you're trying to serve
where are you in this process
um mostly in the brainstorming i'm i'm
looking at a
subscription box for parents
to disciple their children like a family
ministry why does it have to be
non-profit
uh i don't know profit scares me
why does profit scare you because uh
because it's a ministry thing yeah but
you know ministries have to make
more money than they spend to stay open
so that nonprofit's a tax
distinction yeah nonprofits still take
in
more than they spend or they close
churches right any kind of ministry has
to bring in
more income than it has expenses or it
closes
so non-profit is not an actual
difference in the uh
in the income versus the expenses it's a
tax
issue it's just how you categorize the
profit is all
the profit is still there if the motive
is ministry
um i run a ministry
right which i'm very appreciative of i
appreciate that but i'm just saying
so the point is non-profit does not make
something holy
right or right or righteous or
better than the greedio capitalist or
something like that it doesn't
so that's all i'm challenging you on
because a non-profit honestly
we i have one i have a foundation and i
have another non-profit that i've
basically wanted to have wound down
because they're more trouble than
they're worth
unless it's the entire model of what
you're going to do because you've got a
board
you don't have control if you run it the
way the irs wants you to run it
um so i'm that's the only reason i'm
pushing back on it
there's nothing wrong with it so let's
say that we go back to your original
question when is it okay
for you to receive that when uh if you
just switch shoes with your donor where
are you going to raise money people
going to give you money for
to cause this to happen right yes
okay so switch shoes with your donor
stand over in the donor shoes look back
at your non-profit
and go okay they brought in a hundred
thousand dollars and she took a 95 000
salary that feels icky right
right yes okay they brought in a hundred
thousand dollars and she took thirty
thousand for her part-time work that
doesn't feel icky to me does it to you
no so that's how you judge it is just
switch moccasins for a minute
and walk a mile on the other guys
moccasins and then you can kind of see
what's going on
um because we you know the ramsey family
foundation we donate
uh lots of money to ministries that we
select each year in the budget
and one of the things we're looking for
is the icky factor
right right dave if i'm not mistaken
correct me if i'm wrong you know more
about this than i do i would
i would assume but isn't there a
suggested percentage
of what an executive director of a
non-profit should make in
in proportion to the amount of money
that the uh non-profit brings in
there probably is but it would probably
change by the size
yes so like if you had something huge
like the red cross
that would be a different person it'd be
much smaller it's proportion it
proportions if you had a small
non-profit it would usually be a larger
percentage would go to
staff yeah and so forth so so i
i would just say there's two things to
look at one is just don't
you know from a standpoint of donors
coming in
don't violate the icky factor and if
someone challenges you on that then
they're just not one of your donors
that's okay because you felt good about
the amount
that you had as a percentage of the
overall
uh for this coming budget year you know
whatever that is
then the second thing is is ken and i
are both telling you pan back a little
bit
and rethink why a non-profit
because if you're if you're doing this
ministry to kids
um and you know you had uh
a percentage of let's say you want to do
this for
kids that are underprivileged
financially and
kids that are privileged financially
then you might take
some percentage of the ones you sell
and use it to donate like like uh bomba
socks
every time you buy a pair of socks from
bombas they give a pair of socks to the
homeless
you see what i'm doing but they're but
they're for profit
they're for profit and they've given
away two million pairs of socks to
homeless
pretty strong ministry and i've got
bomba socks on at this moment they used
to be an advertiser for us here that's
how i got to meet the guys and for you
you met him in new york right yeah
absolutely and i have got a pair on as
well so that's uh
you know who who did that that's damon
johnson damon john invested in them from
the shark tank
speakers here's the thing uh chelsea
dave's exactly exactly right
it's about the mission for you it's not
about the classification
i would do a for-profit i'd keep it
clean and simple you just have less work
that you have to just to even launch a
non-profit dave as you know
before you've even really kind of proven
the model there's a lot of paperwork a
lot of work you got to do
i still think it's necessary in this
case yeah but do business for good
it's okay yeah it's okay to to do it
either way
sure nothing wrong with either way i
just i want our
um the people out there that are
thinking about things like this to to
do two things one is understand
non-profit
is not in the bible
it's not it's nowhere in the bible
it's a it's an irs tax code
so if the irs has to anoint you wholly
you're screwed
[Music]
so you you know you decide whether
you're going to be holy or not based on
the way you behave the way you serve
the weight whether you're greedy whether
you're generous
how you act and how you behave not
whether or not you make a profit
and so this thing from the communist and
socialist
college professors that have taught
everyone that capitalism is evil
has got to stop because it's accurate
it's inaccurate
biblically it's an accurate in truth
there are wonderful companies that are
for profit to do a great job again not
saying
that there's anything wrong with doing a
not for profit
i've got a good friend uh craig groschel
bobby grunwald over at life church
they obviously life church is a
non-profit and they have the
largest bible app one of the largest
apps of all of apple everyone's got it
on their phone
and it's a complete non-profit they give
it away for free
they put money into it it loses money
every year it's called you version by
boy app
they've got 500 million half a billion
people around the world using this bible
app
completely free and completely donated
that thing
where it to be commercial would be worth
billions and billions of dollars
as a company and that asset is owned by
that church
and it is an asset even though they give
it away for free and it doesn't make any
money
because 500 million people looking at
anything is an asset
in this world today so that's a
non-profit that's done extremely well
and run with excellence they're friends
of ours
we participate providing content ramsey
content to the
new version bible app they're wonderful
people they they're professional
in how they operate the thing it's not
half but run like some non-profits are
or some ministries are but um
so there's an example of when it's done
right chelsea like you want to do it
that's cool
but if you gonna do the kits to the kids
and it's gonna be for profit you're to
collect money from the
customer it does present you with
another challenge you have to provide
value
that's exactly and it gives you a
wake-up call on that
too so it's a great discussion i
discussed a long time
with ramsey when we were starting this
whether it was going to be
not-for-profit
and that's how i i kind of had to
germinate on all these philosophies and
really think through
is is it is it as a christian is it okay
to make a profit i had to go through
those things
and as my friend rabbi lapin says that
when you serve people well
they give you certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on
them
they're green and the way that we say
thank you
is with a tip yeah thank you for serving
me
thank you and i don't think anything
about it i i'm
honored to give a great server a great
tip
i don't think they're a greedy
capitalist no
i'm glad they got it